all right here's something from Jared
Conner and also right into us on
Facebook dr. Tyson can solar systems
formed in the intergalactic medium if so
could there be planets in those solar
systems with intelligent life so this
person has vocabulary yes
intergalactic medium all right so what
we have is between the planets we call
that interplanetary medium between the
stars interstellar medium that every
collection of stars that we find is part
of a galaxy then there's this void
between the galaxies could we have stars
there yes but our best understanding of
all this tells us that these are stars
that may have been formed out of a
galaxy typically in a galaxy collision
that they're really train wrecks when
they happen and when they do stars fly
hither and yon so they just escape the
train there at night and they're on
their own escape the train and they're
on their own so they're rogue stars
basically that's the word the rogue
starts just the same way you can have
planets wandering between the stars
we call them rogue planets okay you can
have rogue stars cast asunder
after a galactic collision we have
galactic collisions all the time uh-huh
and so there's no reason why you
couldn't yes and these are stars that
are basically homeless in a way oh oh
did they have signs that say will shine
for food they're homeless homeless stars
almost hi galactic homeless stars yeah
so there's no reason to but it would be
very hard to see them because stars are
not dim stars a too dim to give us
enough light across intergalactic space
for us to tell that they're there okay
so they're not staying still long enough
for us to see so you can stay still but
you're one damn star in the middle of a
void and think about it when you look
out between when you look out out of our
galaxy
right you need awesome telescopes to see
only the brightest stars in other
galaxies otherwise it's the merge puddle
of light from the hundred billion stars
themselves
guys guys you're not picking them out
picking on that one at a time no you're
not ah